hello
here goes the pull
you can answer in the poll widget I'm
going to leave that open for just
another five seconds for
three
two one
and
it's a bimodal distribution we have and
about a third of our audience or so who
are currently still studying and about
40 percent who have more than five years
experience
so
thank you for that and that gives me an
idea of who is in our audience today as
I mentioned
we're going to here now from Professor
management Yani
and we had him with us live a month ago
he couldn't join us again today
unfortunately because of a scheduling
conflict
but I wanted to share with you what he
had to say with us
then so he's going to describe some of
the program a bit I'll come back and
describe more of it and how to enroll
and a special bonus offer and after that
um
I'll take some more additional questions
he's going to share with you answers to
questions that other
people had asked
here we go
make sure I'm doing this correctly
all right as the slide says uh let me
introduce myself hi my name is Manoj
murtiani I work with I am indu for last
10 years and I am currently associate
prop in the marketing area before coming
to uh I am indoor I completed my PhD
from my member before that I worked in
industry for a period of time at
adityability lab group as well as at
godrej consumer private limited as a
scholar I have published few papers and
possibly a few of the reports which are
available in both media and possibly in
the search portrait and we do a small
amount of Consulting work for various
companies as well as possibly some ngos
to work with my research interests as a
professor is in the field of Sales
Management Service marketing neural
marketing these would be few areas in
which I am more interested in terms of
doing my research Consulting and
training to explain you about I am
indoor I am indoor was established in
1996 so we in some sense are the second
Generations I am which got started up by
government of India we have to
accomplish this one main campus which is
in I am Indore where we actually host
all our programs which include pgp IPM
epjp all full-time programs which are
run from I am indoor Bean campus we also
have another auxiliary campus in Mumbai
its main target is to possibly have the
cater management development programs
and also we run our pgpmx program which
is basically a full-time two years
program but the classes only happen in
weekend and given you have some 5-10
years of experience to our religion
rank 7 our Global MBA ranks 25th in the
Asia I'm just so sorry I'll just give
the answers of all the questions you're
putting on the chat uh just after
finishing this we have a proper q a
route we are also being accredited by
acbs number as well as equal
certification which is called triple
crowd so in India we are this only
second Institute which has the true
double crown in this country which is
the three different certifications which
are a Hallmark of the quality of the
education which I am in the provide
now when we talk about this specific
program
this is the executive certificate
program in general management its
duration would be six months and it
exits five to ten hours per week of work
the idea for this particular program was
the people who want to have some sort of
an exposure for the general Management
program and obviously it's not feasible
for them to attend any full-time
programs possibly they would be the one
who would be most benefited out of it we
have a comprehensive curriculum which is
aligned to the industry in terms of
learning path so whatever the core
structure which has been selected is
assuming that we will have a courses
right from The Beginner's level to
possibly a little bit of an advanced
level so that you can cover the entire
spectrum and it is assumed you have work
experience so many of the uh
organization related things you guys
would be able to use them to create the
most out of this particular program
there will be a Hands-On projects for
practical experience one of that we will
discuss later would be the Capstone
project you will have an online live
virtual classroom classes apart from the
asynps classes so that you will have a
flexibility in terms of completing this
course based on your time frame as many
of the lectures are asynchronous that
means you will see the recording and
plus just to strengthen the aspect of
what we have covered we'll also have a
live classes where the instructors would
come and have an interaction with you
related to the curriculum which they
have covered which gives you a little
bit of flexibility in terms of
completing this course so after
completing this course you will be
getting a certificate from I am indoor
which will be uh classifying you that
you have completed your executive
program here and you will get a status
of I am indoor alumni executor right so
that would be the status which you will
be getting there will be a three days
campus immersion program for which there
is an additional cost so that means you
can come to the campus experience it
there will be also classes uh which will
be conducted in those three days if you
don't attain that still if you are able
to complete the other requirement let me
talk about the structure and design of
this particular program so we'll start
with the orientation sessions which
basically talk about what we'll be
covering in this particular course what
would be the main idea basic processing
of how your classes will be conducting
the test which you have to pass with
that we'll start with a smaller module
which will be talking about the
Foundations of Management when we
briefly go toward understanding the
economic side of business accounting
then trying to go towards a more
specialized functional courses like
operation management supply chain
marketing management human resource then
talking about something which is much
more relevant possibly even at the
senior level which would be in the field
of business analytics management and
Leadership strategy design thinking
digital disruption and Innovation and
then there will be a Capstone project so
in the Capstone project what is this
supposed to do is we'll be requesting
you to pick up a live problem a
functional problem from your company on
which you would be working and then at
the end of the course you have to
present this particular problem how you
were able to tackle it what were some
things which you were able to do with it
which would be also part of your
evaluation and it gives a complete
feedback loop system completed that you
after understanding about the basics of
the courses you are able to execute them
to solve the real life problems so that
is how possibly this particular program
would like to structure
all right so at this point we would like
to take some of your questions and I'm
going to look both in the chat in the Q
a starting with the Q a
um
we had a question from a user who wants
to know if you could compare the
executive postgraduate certificate
programming management executive
postgraduate management
e
uh pgp and pgb MX yeah yeah okay
let me explain you the difference
between these three different types of
operating when we talk about pgpmx
course or epgp codes they are degree
courses which are offered by I am indoor
so if you write classes in Mumbai campus
on the weekend days this process they
will continue for two years after which
they will be completing their degree
which will be talking about pgp mxdb
compared to these two programs when you
talk about the general Management
program its duration is six months so
and it offers you a certificate not a
degree which is a little different you
can understand the technical difference
between these two things second
obviously in pgp MX and epgp programs
all the classes are on campus live
classes compared to this we have Asian
Plus classes as well as simplest classes
so in terms of both the content it's
execution and the final outcome these
three programs have a very different
types of audience in mind
thank you
um Amit asks if if he has his MBA from
Pune University
and 15 years of experience uh is this an
appropriate program for him or would you
um recommend something else okay so see
just by having the line that you have a
15 years of experience in MBA it becomes
very difficult for me to give you a
ready-made solution but let me explain
you possibly what this program can do
for you and possibly what this program
won't be able to do for you see if you
have a 15 years of experience and you
are looking for a refresher in the sense
you want to refresh about the basic
concepts which are there in the
management and possibly upgrade yourself
in terms of what has happened in 15
years in terms of the management
principle that might be a great course
for you in case if you're looking for a
degree program possibly this is not the
right place to get a degree program or
possibly if your objective is that you
are looking for a Senior Management
specific roles right again this program
is not talking about specialization in a
very specific thing for example there
are programs which are very very
specific only in terms of dealership or
data Sciences this program is actually
not trying to achieve that so depending
upon what exactly you are seeking this
program might be good for you or
possibly this my program might not be a
right fit for you
thank you
um we have a question from someone in
Malaysia if the certificate is
recognized there
okay when we talk about certificates
recognization I am not sure about what
are the some specific requirements in
Malaysia generally when you go to other
countries Whenever there is a degree
when you claim there is a degree it has
to be approved from that particular
government because this is not a degree
program if you are looking it as a
diploma program or certificate program I
think it might be considered as a degree
not a degree program but a certificate
program by the Malaysian government but
because it is decided by that particular
country I think we would like to check
it before you we give you a very very
strong response whether it will be
recognized in some sense thank you
um
asked if this is for undergraduate
students and if you could go over some
of them believe this program is not for
undergrad students right basically the
idea is you would have already completed
your undergrad so this is not a program
that you are currently in the first year
of your undergrad and you are trying to
do this program the purpose of this
program is not for undergrad
we have a couple of questions about
price and I will talk about that uh a
little bit later in the webinar
um so please stay on board for that
um
and someone asked if the certificate
would be physical and not digital
um and I believe we issue a digital
certificate do you know uh for sure the
answer to that Professor we gave a
digital certificate but they'll be QR
code right which talks about its
uniqueness
okay and which will help you to
recognize that who has been
uh given that anshita this is not a
forum where I can give you our tips for
the current exam so once this is the
wrong place to ask that question
going through the chat now to see if
there is this course also available for
U.S students
this program is available for all
students for all the countries because
it's a online program but you need to
see whether this time would get
synchronized with you or whether it
needs a requirement
and you'd be able to check the website
to find out what a general
recommendation which I'll make later is
to contact us uh through our email
address to talk to a learning consultant
um
previous campus immersion
in this is validatories how many planned
in these three days or any time uh know
the valedictory ceremony will happen on
the three days of the campus visit only
okay and as you mentioned the course
requires work experience that was one of
the questions here so you do have to
come into this as the working
professional is that correct yes okay
I think that covers all of the questions
let me see if anything else is come in
know that you have a time limit
professor
do you have a few well I'd like to
answer yeah I'll surely wait in case if
anyone has a cushion a totally like to
answer that okay and uh so we have a
question if the program is beneficial
from someone who wants to Pivot out of
the education sector into the corporate
sector
okay
okay so please understand if you are
from education sector I don't know at
which level you are whether you're a
school teacher or working possibly in a
college so depending upon the graduation
degrees which you have all the post
graduation degree which you have after
which you have got into academics as a
career maybe this General Management
program will help you to get a general
idea about how management functions
right so at some roles it might be
benefited but I'll be very honest with
you that this is not a degree program so
please understand after that you will
also have to work as they will be
providing you an opportunity to upload
your CVS on in terms of job but you need
to start your first step on your own to
build your management career thank you
um
we have an attendee who was able to join
late uh I want to assure everyone that
we will be sending an email after this
session uh get it in the next day or two
with a link to the recording of the
session so you'll be able to review this
um we had
we have two more questions I think yeah
I think so sneha says can we do the can
you do the course uh if you're preparing
for MBA entrance
my suggestion would be if you're
preparing for an MBA entrance this
program might not be directly beneficial
for you in any way to prepare for a MBA
because it will go in your MBA possibly
they have a very different curriculum
right so if you are looking for thinking
in terms of benefits for your MBA I
think then that's not a right way to
pick up the choice uh because in case if
you're doing MB it's a totally different
path but suppose you are someone who is
planning to learn about management
because it will be useful for your
current job or possibly in terms of the
career opportunities which are looking
this might be a useful course for you
thank you we have a question from a data
scientist who wants to move up into
management
um beyond the
analytical role in is this a good course
for that
so if you're a data scientist and you
think that maybe in your organization it
is required that you should have an
awareness about General management
concept for example you might be very
good in terms of doing a cluster
analysis right but possibly you are also
running it for the marketing department
to help them with the segmentation
problem in this program you will
understand exactly what is the things
which about which they were looking for
a Solutions so if you are knowledge
about General management increase I
think it might be beneficial because you
will get a much better perspective about
what exactly you are doing in terms of
crunching those numbers so it might be
useful for you to move up the ladder
because you will have a apart from
technical expertise uh idea about the
general management
and Professor you'd like to look through
the
questions in the Q a and pick the ones
that uh most appeal to you because
I think there's
a few down here there's one about
opportunities
no go ahead no you go ahead so I'll just
go in the reverse chronicle order
whether it will be useful for project
management sector again a large project
management sector itself is a huge
sector if you are someone who is in a
domain specific job related to project
management and you would like to get an
exposure and if uh to understand how the
general management work how these inter
departments work then possibly this
program would be very suitable for you
to get a general idea about how possibly
the organization work as a career this
okay let me answer I think one more
question has come
uh
is this program turned as EP
G and program of this epgn program have
one year duration how this
program okay please understand this is a
executive program this is not a degree
granting program so the program which
you are referring to which is called
epgp program that's a degree granting
program which is one year of duration
which happens in campus so this is not
exactly that one year program which we
have divided into two pieces the program
which you are talking about is a very
separate program compared to our epgp
program which is a residential program
which finally result into a degree
so it's very different in terms of
content and possibly its delivery and
the final outcome I can ask a question
about exams and the process of
assessments and tests on this in this
program uh can you mention a little bit
about that
sure so with every module when you would
be covering a module there will be an
exam which is basically McQ most of the
time there will be an McQ exam which is
there you have to give that exam and
score a suitable marks so that we get an
assurance that you were able to
understand that particular subject once
you have cleared all these exams there's
a Capstone project in a Capstone project
as I stated we will request you to
identify one problem from your
organization which is related to a
specific domain you will be doing an
industry analysis plus obviously in this
course there are domain specific modules
so you'll be also getting some insight
from the domain specific module which
would be covered and it is expected that
you will use that input to come up with
a report some sort of a presentation
which would be presenting to us in terms
of how you were able to approach to that
be considered as a Capstone project
okay and I think the last question could
not heard of for example design thinking
it's happening in terms of management
and that has been aligned in this
particular program to make sure that it
is most relevant for the participants
wonderful thank you Professor
um
and I think that is all the time we have
part of the presentation
and I'll get to your
live questions in a little bit
we talk about management because the
digital economy requires managers who
have
digital understanding and you saw in the
scope of the curriculum that we're
covering all aspects of General
management of
um
you do need these kinds of skills to to
succeed
and this is why the program covers broad
range including the
financial and accounting economics
through the operations Supply Chain
management through marketing Analytics
and these are intended to support you in
whatever career path you have going
through management so
if you are an individual contributor
you can use these skills to help you
understand and move up in management if
you are already at the senior level you
can broaden your skill base
the program of this type
and Professor matiani is one
of a number of professors I I Endure who
are involved with and deliver this
program so
part of a very religious cohort
professor dush in finance professor
ostogian
economics
Professor matiani is mainly marketing
Professor is also in operations and
Analytics
professor kodwani in organizational
management human behavior
of Professor Basu who is primarily
finance and Professor bullor who's also
marketing so
these are the Advisory Board not the uh
only people who will be delivering the
program but you'll interact with many of
them and
to reiterate you use as a program that
requires you to be a working
professional so this is a
if you're still studying you'll want to
wait until you have your bachelor's
degree which is a minimum requirement
for this program
and you need to have two or more years
of work experience
which can of course be in any field you
could be from any background
I do not have to have technology
background you don't have to have a
financer uh
accounting background coming from this
program from anywhere
so
uh I just want to mention that it's
delivered entirely digitally
it's delivered to your desktop there's a
live virtual classroom as Professor
matiani mentioned
there are multiple tests and assessments
each
step in that curriculum requires that
you clear an assessment
and that unlocks the next course in the
curriculum
uh you do projects and case studies
including that Capstone project
and you have access to 24x7 support so
you'll be able to interact with your
professor's instructors live in the
virtual classroom environment on a
weekly set schedule and then
be able to do all the other work at
income 24 7 on your own schedule so
talk about a couple a couple of things
relating to learn outcomes previous
batches of the class
have had people coming in from all
different sorts of organizations
so you will be
able to network with your batchmates
may come from companies like IBM or Tata
um shell HP Amazon Amazon
and across all different Industries so
this is not just a
digital technology oriented this is a
general management for all Industries
we also provide a simply learn the
delivery partner with IIM indoor
we provide job assistance so for six
months after you earn your certificate
you have access to services
with IIM jobs this is specifically for
Learners in India and this allows you to
support your job search not a job
placement service but if you are using
this program to help you get a
new or better job we can assist you with
membership to the IAM jobs job portal
uh premium level for six months
and also get help with your resume
review and rewrite Services which are
all important for navigating the
automated tracking systems and AI Bots
that do the first screen of your resume
these days
um you want a resume that can pass that
process but still appeal to the human
being who sees it after
uh you pass the filter of the AI so this
is a valuable service and so is the
one-on-one interview prep which prepares
you for all the interview types ranging
from the phone screen to the technical
interview to the management fit and
teamwork interviews so these are all
available as I said for six months after
you earn your certificate
so at this point I just like to ask if
you might be interested in this program
based on what you have heard
so far
I'm going to
launch this poll
and I'll share with you some more
details but we'll go into q a in a
minute
and I'll close the poll in another five
seconds for
three two one hit that submit button
and
85 percent of you said you are
interested and I'm going to share with
you some details about that
enrollment process is pretty
straightforward you email us at ask us
at simplylearn.net
and we will
send to you
the information for enrollment and ask
you for the documentation of your
education work experience I'm going to
put in the chat right now this
information
all right
so we'll send evaluate your
qualifications if you are qualified for
the program we'll send you an admission
offer
our next cohort starts on 20 May
so if you'd like to get started reach
out to us right away
there is a bonus for doing so
bonus is that you can take 20 off of the
program fees this program totals two
luck 47 800 rupee and can be Emi
financed at 84.
36 a month not either for 336 sorry for
the typo
um
but it also uh as I said you can take a
20 discount from the program fees for
being here at this webinar so
thank you very much this is applies to
new enrollments only
and how soon if you are planning to join
the program how soon
sorry
would you plan to enroll
it's this poll question
would you want to get started in the
cohort coming up at the end of the week
or do you want to look at
perhaps the next one in August
or one later on
we talk about the need to enroll early
because the cohort sizes have to be
limited there's live interaction live
instruction so we can't have unlimited
cohort sizes we try to keep them to
about 30
learner's maximum
and let me end the poll here and the
results
so uh about 40 percent of our audience
would like to get started either right
away or in the
cohort right after this one
and for those who are looking further
down the road
please do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net we'll keep in touch with
you and keep
uh advised uh before we get to this last
question here I want to answer your
q a so
let me pull up your questions that have
came up come in live
see which ones Professor motioni didn't
um
experience of 3.8 years in sales and
marketing and want to change an industry
domain
um so Executive MBA without a record
regular MBA regular MBA
oh
or a program like this one it depends on
what your um
desired change is so darshan if you're
changing your
industry domain
you're looking for more domain knowledge
um you might be looking for different
information than what an MBA
provide you if you're looking to move up
in your organization and develop your
general management skills
you might look at this program which is
six months which gives you the
background across different skill areas
and
then make a decision based on that on
whether to then further pursue an MBA
um it's not clear
from your question whether you want to
get the MBA in order to be able to move
up in management but
um shift of Industry domain is more a
matter of
the domain knowledge rather than General
management knowledge
we covered the costs can freshers join
the course
again this is targeted to people who
have at least two years of experience
after graduating so you want to make
sure that you meet that qualification
um
the
Target of the course for people who have
some experience in the workplace and
want and have some understanding of how
it works so that they can then apply
these management techniques
uh
so I have completed the pgdib from
symbiosis more than eight years of
experience uh I'm not familiar with that
qualification if it's a bachelor's
degree that should be
adequate for joining the program here
um and then again it depends on what is
what it is that you want to pursue in
your career uh if this
is the right program for you
percentage also matter or not
um we're just you do have to have 50
marks in your
your academic record
will you be mentioning that I am a
indoor alumni status you'll be certainly
able to share the the certificate
award status once you've earned your
certificate
and publicly announced that and you're
very proudly
um
so
talked about that
project project uh your chemical
engineer
four years of experience and operations
if you are looking to broaden your
understanding of your organization and
move into General management
so that you can move to
level of department head
or
vice president or even higher in the
organization
this type of General management
knowledge will be extremely helpful to
you
be more effective in
those kinds of roles
is there any exam to shortlist
candidates or will there be an exam at
the end of the award uh there are simple
assessment exams as part of the
enrollment process but they're they're
just to make sure that you have basic
aptitude but the main exams that are
done throughout the course culminate in
the Capstone project the Capstone
project
where you provide a solution to a case
study that's presented to you
and that acts as the final exam that
shows that you can integrate all of the
different learnings from the different
courses within the program so
that's really
the purpose is this equivalent to an
Executive MBA this is not at the level
of an Executive MBA that would be a
little bit more into
um
a little bit longer a little bit more
intense
but this has the elements of an
Executive MBA in terms of
covering all of the different management
areas and skills
uh guarding the Capstone project what
are we supposed to do if we weren't
aren't working in an organization at a
particular time
so with respect to that you would work
with your instructors
to create a simulated environment for
how you would carry out this uh
this program if you were working at a
new organization so
that's an accommodation that
um
I.T professional with over 30 years of
experience
so how can this help you with career
growth this again gives people who are
functional experts in a particular uh
area in a particular domain
broader skills to be able to understand
the other aspects of organization its
strategic goals on how different
areas support those goals and how you
can participate in management both
within your your functional area but
also on a more General level and so this
this helps to facilitate moving up in
management
skills for managing your group better
and then moving into more General roles
um
talked about that
how to Avail the discount
when you contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and you will receive a
follow-up email with details uh on the
discount as well so you can request that
and
um mentioned that you were at this
webinar
but the follow-up email will also
include a discount code
what certificate will you be given and
the certificate I think we showed an
example earlier on is the certificate
from IIM indoor
um
certifies that you have met the
requirements the program to their
satisfaction
simply learn is the delivery partner
um program is an IAM indoor program
and the start date for the next classes
is the 20th of May
let me
check in the chat window to see what
other questions may be here
duration of the course six months online
only
you can do this from wherever you are
much of the material is available to you
on your tablet or smartphone if you're
looking at some of the pre-recorded
materials but you do need to be able to
join the live classes which is best done
from the desktop or laptop
um I'm looking that back through
assessment methodology there are
quizzes assessments at the end of each
module
the instructor May assign to you
um
actually homework assignments
so and there is preparation that you
want to do in preparation for each
week's live session so
system will track that
um
it will give you prompts if you are
if you've missed some some classes or
assignments it'll prompt you to catch up
and keep track of what what's going on
so it helps support your success in that
way as well
so I'm going to ask this last poll
question here I hope I have answered
questions
I think I've covered everything that's
in the chat and Q a
so my question here is
do you need assistance you would you
like us to reach out proactively to you
to answer any questions
and to help you get started
I'll leave this open for another 10
seconds
close that and
five four three two one
and so for the the 40 of you who said
that you're interested in getting we
will contact you everybody will be
receiving
share that everybody will be receiving
um
email with a link to the recording of
the session information on claiming your
discount
and also receive proof of attendance for
this session
and with that I want to thank you all
for being here
and for expressing interest in the
program from IIM indoor
the QR code will take you to the
program page
on our website I will also put that into
the chat right now
and
make that available to you
and you'll be able to see some further
details about the program
an example of the certificate
and other details about cohort dates and
enrollment
also you'll be able to check pricing for
your local area if you happen not to be
in India
and with that I want to say again thank
you to all all of you for being here
appreciate your taking your time this
evening and we hope we can welcome you
into the Learning Community with IIM
indoor and simply learn
that concludes our webinar
foreign
[Music]